[Musique]
la cena été capturées par les caméras de
vidéosurveillance pendant près de cinq
minutes on voit un homme se faire
frapper à plusieurs reprises par trois
policiers
y a pas besoin de jouer au cluedo pour
savoir qui est le responsable de ces
crimes industriel parce qu'il y en a un
qui était toujours là dans la pièce
macron secrétaire général adjoint de
l'elysée macron ministre de l'économie
et des finances au holland macron
président de la république aujourd'hui
il est à chaque fois départ de l'action
vallourec
mais voilà sarkozy lundi arrive
accompagnée de son avocate
jacqueline laffont le three peat mans et
l'appareil photo qui se traduisent
aujourd'hui par des dizaines d'incendiés
d'emplois supprimés allez juste nancy
c'est chacun son tour c'est un peu le
principe de l'interview franchement ça
va tellement vite je me demande même si
c'est des vrais policiers
à ce moment là je ne sais pas si c'est
vrai plaisir quand je lui parle de
s'expliquer et là il me dit quoi on sale
[ __ ] ta gueule on va te défoncer
finalement neuf jeunes artistes présents
dans le studio lui viennent en aide et
met les policiers dehors il ne faut pas
céder à l'émotion des images elles ne
sont pas suffisantes pour condamner
d'emblée des policiers ces derniers
appellent des renforts et jette une
grenade lacrymogène à l'intérieur de
l'appartement pour l'obliger à sortir
des locaux
ces images elles sont inqualifiables
sont extrêmement choquantes et dès que
j'ai pris connaissance de celle ci ce
qui s'était passé j'ai demandé la
suspension de ces policiers et dès que
les faits seront établis par la justice
puisqu'elle est saisie je demanderai la
révocation de ces policiers ils ont sali
l'uniforme de la république sur ces
images ce n'est pas une police
républicaine mais une milice barbares
hors de contrôle
le préfet l'allemand doit partir si
c'était un fait dans une manif et que
tout le reste du temps ça se passait
bien je vous dirais bon ben voilà c'est
tout et l'unc a déconné mais si c'est
tout le temps que le presseur police de
paris et moi je dis je connais comme
vous le dites le préfet l'allemand je
pourrais citer le tweet du conseiller de
l'elysée
stéphane et journée qui lui même dit
c'est à lui de faire appliquer la loi
par la police est-ce qu'il doit
démissionner je suis forcément
scandalisé par ces images dire que la
république un problème avec les
violences policières
c'est pas vrai mais dire que chaque
violence policière est un problème pour
la république
ça c'est une réalité moi je suis pas un
homme qui est recherché
les fusibles ou des boucs émissaires
préfet l'allemand
c'est un préfet qui exercent une mission
difficile et je souhaite qu'il continue
d'exercer cette mission parce qu'ils
fassent comme didier je suis le
responsable je suis mise en intérieur et
vous garde des sceaux a fait son devoir
non sans regret je le cite la
déclaration de patrimoine des ministres
visés légitimement à savoir s'il
s'enrichissent dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions au gouvernement de la
transparence au voyeurisme
il n'y a qu'un pas que certains
franchissent pour s'y vautrer qu'un
appartement de son mètre carré à paris
un million 8 en 2010 à vos deux millions
huit aujourd'hui il ya un appartement de
107 mètres carrés dans la capitale il ya
une bentley mais l'autre drame du jour
c'est l'arrivée de marlène chaîne trace
sur tik tok le réseau social préféré des
ados a vu débarquer hier la ministre
déléguée à la citoyenneté
salut jeunes entrepreneurs navale
mariage ça va déjà les sorties ptac une
moto une harley davidson il a un bateau
il à 470 mille euros sur son compte
bancaire
je ne laisserai tomber personne du petit
restaurateur jusqu'aux grands chefs et
solistes votre slogan printemps pour les
entreprises en général c'était zéro
faillite vous souvenez de cette engage
sur et pour les restaurants laissez nous
travailler vous voyez sur cette
banderole que je vais vous dire il a
écrit fait du bruit pour nous aider à ne
pas mourir en silence ce que veulent en
fait les patrons des restaurants j'ai
l'habitude de dire les choses avec
franchise je ne prendrai pas cet
engagement
je sais que des restaurants qui ont du
mal à survivre à cette période j'en ai
parfaitement conscience